about five tons of objects made up of
interstellar dust hits the earth's
atmosphere at high velocity on a daily
basis
most of them are rather small and so
they burn up in the atmosphere without a
trace
as a rule those that make it to the
surface fall in areas with either low
population
or no population at all in short the
good news is the risk of getting hurt by
falling asteroid is infinitely small
still if a considerably larger object
were to hit our planet
the consequences would be much more
serious
there were precedents in the history of
our earth and there is no guarantee it
will not happen again
over a thousand celestial bodies are
posing a potential threat today
so what would happen if a really large
asteroid were to collide with us
[Music]
cosmo the first in outer space
but before we take a look at this
scenario i'd like to remind you of our
channel in telegram
if you haven't seen it yet do check it
out there is a lot of exciting stuff
about space and science
the link is in this video's description
and now back to the story
large objects do approach our planets
now and then
for example on the 14th of november 2020
asteroid 2020 vt4 with a diameter
measuring about 10 meters
past our earth at a distance of 383
kilometers from the surface
that is below the international space
station and most satellites
even though known potential threats are
monitored by scientists at all times
the problem is that most asteroids are
rather dark objects
whose dimensions are quite modest by
space standards
which makes them hard to detect however
an explosion caused by an impact of a
celestial body with a diameter of just
10 meters
would be tantamount to the atomic
bombing of hiroshima
it may not leave any radioactive waste
but a blast this powerful would wipe a
little town right off the face of the
earth
an asteroid with a diameter measuring 50
meters
that is as big as a modern multi-storey
building would unleash a power of
several dozen kilotons on impact
which would be enough to raise an entire
city almost to the ground
if an asteroid this large were to fall
into an ocean
it would cause a tsunami reaching up to
10 meters
which would drink destruction all the
way it went traveling for hundreds and
thousands of kilometers from the site of
its impact
where this asteroid's diameter to
measure a kilometer or so
it would cause mass destruction
throughout an entire continent
the force of the explosion on impact
could reach as much as thousands of
megatons and tnt equivalent
and its consequences would haunt the
planet for many years to come
it is highly likely that the human
civilization would not survive a
calamity of this scale
nor would other living creatures with
the only exception of protozoans and
exceptionally enduring organisms
mass extinction events did take place in
the history of our earth the most
notorious of them cretaceous tertiary
extinction event
about 66 million years ago it is posited
that dinosaurs and a number of other
species died out as a result of it
as for the most large-scale mass
extinction event it
took place approximately 251 million
years ago
coming in between the permian and the
triassic periods
based on results of paleontological
diggings it was estimated that about 90
percent of sea species
and 70 percent land species died out as
a result
one of the things that caused both of
these dramatic calamities
is believed to be the fall of a large
asteroid
today the number of potentially
dangerous objects is estimated to be in
the region of one and a half to two
thousand
although this number may reach four to
six thousand according to the data
provided by the wise telescope
since they're so small and dark these
celestial objects are rather hard to
spot
for example the size of the asteroid
dubbed 2008 dc3
which burned up in the atmosphere just
above sudan in 2008
was anything from 2 to 5 meters it was
spotted just 20 hours before it would
have impacted
the earth fortunately nobody was hurt
there is a special rating scale known as
the palermo scale
it is a generalized scale reflecting
potential impact risk
posed by this or that celestial body
which takes into account the body's
kinetic energy and the probability of
hitting the earth
the higher the value the bigger the
threat to our planet
if a body's palermo scale value is below
-2
this body is practically safe asteroids
with values between
-2 and 0 do not pose any immediate
threat
but require monitoring at all times as
for objects with a value
above zero they are realistically
dangerous for the earth
at this point there isn't a single
celestial object out there with a
positive palermo scale value
and there are only two asteroids in the
yellow alert zone
that is their value is between -2 and 0.
both of them fall into the category of
the apollo asteroids
celestial bodies whose perihelion lies
closer to the sun than the earth's
aphelion
and whose orbital semi-major axis is
bigger than that of the earth
thus these objects cross our planet's
orbit from the outside
the bennu asteroid designation 1999
rq36 with a potential hazard index value
minus
1.69 poses a smaller threat to the two
in the year 2135 it will find itself
just 300 000 kilometers away from the
earth
which is slightly closer to us than the
moon bennu's average diameter measures
approximately 500 meters
and the asteroid's mass is anything
between 60 to 78 million tons
if it were to collide with our earth the
resulting explosion would be tantamount
to about a thousand megatons and tnt
equivalent
which would almost certainly cause major
catastrophic disasters all over the
planet
in 2016 nasa launched the osiris-rex
probe to bennu in order to obtain
samples of the minerals making up the
asteroid the probe is scheduled to get
back to the earth in 2023
the more hazardous of the two asteroids
is 1950 d
a with a palomo scale value minus 1.42
today it has the highest probability of
hitting our earth
its diameter measures about 1.3
kilometers
and its mass can be anything from 2 to 4
billion tons
1950 da's orbit is elongated and
elliptical
and it crosses the orbits of our earth
and mars
1950 da's closest approach to the earth
is expected in 2035
but a hazardous approach will take place
only as late as on the 16th of march
[Music]
what would await us if the asteroid did
impact the earth
let's assume no preventive measures have
been successful to deflect this body
and the disaster is inevitable
an enormous chunk of rock with a
diameter almost
one and a half kilometers and a mass
that could be two to four billion tons
heading towards the earth at a speed of
about 14 kilometers per second
this would be the speed of 1950 d a at
the moment it hit the earth
if an impact event did occur as
estimated by nasa
of course part of the matter making up
1950 da would burn up and disperse in
the atmosphere as the asteroid slowed
down
and the main body would be likely to
break up into several large rocks
and a great number of small bits
depending on their size
each of them would cause an explosion of
not less than 20 kilotons on impact with
the earth's crust
that's the average power of a modern
nuclear bomb with a comparatively modest
charge the overall power of the
explosions would most likely be over one
and a half thousand megatons
with a bombarded area larger than that
of europe
all constructions within the radius of
300 to 500 kilometers would be raised to
the ground
and even reinforced underground bunkers
wouldn't guarantee enough safety
the energy of the shock wave would allow
it to sweep around the earth several
times while gradually slowing down
and bringing more destruction on its way
with every lap
if the asteroid were to fall into an
ocean a giant tsunami would rise 40
meters or higher
tsunamis normally travel for thousands
of kilometers
and as they go their destructive forces
practically don't diminish
therefore coastal areas of the
continents lying near the site of the
impact would be submerged in water
with cities and villages effectively
wiped out
multiple impacts of bits of rock would
raise tons of dust in the atmosphere
winds would scatter these dense clouds
all over the sky
and most sunlight would not reach the
planet which would cause a sharp
temperature fall
this phenomenon is known as nuclear
winter
it is highly probable that an impact of
this scale would affect
not only the crust but the mantle as
well
the shock wave would wake up volcanoes
and they would erupt all over the planet
which in its turn would cause the second
wave of tsunamis and earthquakes
tons of ash released in the atmosphere
would contribute to further temperature
drops
there is quite a popular belief that
after an asteroid hit the earth it would
affect its orbit or orbital period
this would lead to dramatic climate
changes and even render the planets
completely incapable of sustaining life
however according to some estimates an
impact of even the biggest asteroid in
the solar system would not be enough to
do so
an object realistically able to
noticeably change the earth's orbit
should be as big as the moon
or pluto at the very least be it as it
may
if it were to happen the consequences of
an impact of this scale would be much
graver than just a change of orbit or
orbital period
the potential impact risk of 1950 da's
hitting our earth is just
0.012 there is no room for complacency
though
as the impact probability may rise
following a change of the asteroid's
orbit as a result of collisions with
other celestial objects that may well
take place
for a long while it was believed that
the humanity hadn't advanced enough to
prevent any hazards of asteroid falls
all we could do was just observe
potentially hazardous objects
actually doing something about them like
destroying an asteroid or changing its
orbit
was confined to science fiction films
and books
however science doesn't stand still even
in 2004 when a threat posed by apophis
was considered grave enough
it was proposed to cover its surface
with light reflecting film
this way sunlight pressure would change
the asteroid's orbit
other suggestions included nuclear
bombings as well as special power
thrusters powerful enough to shift
orbits of celestial bodies
[Music]
in 2018 nasa in collaboration with
spacex
approved the dart program whose aim is
to deflect the asteroid's trajectory by
making it collide with an artificial
spacecraft
the binary near-earth asteroid didymos
made up of two components with diameters
measuring 800
and 150 meters is the target for the
dart demonstration
the launch of the spacecraft is planned
for 2021
celestial bodies on the solar system may
be closely monitored but there is always
a risk of somebody previously unknown to
us
arriving from the galaxy's outskirts and
heading towards the earth
orbital periods of some comets and
asteroids around the earth may last
hundreds and even thousands of years
and their small sizes and dark surfaces
render these potentially dangerous
visitors barely detectable
still the odds of such a disaster as an
impact event are extremely small
and in fact there are many more dangers
that may before the human race on our
own planet
[Music]
you